this episode of the minimalist is
brought to you by nobody because
advertisements suck
non-minimalists
hello everybody welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is joshua fields milburn
and i'm ryan nicodemus and together we
are the minimalists ryan i've been told
that minimalism is the fountain of youth
look at me how so i mean i could go by
nyquil right now and they'd have to card
me
and yet today is my 40th birthday
oh but this episode is not about me
today we're going to celebrate with a
podcast episode about birthday gifts
we're going to talk about gift getting
gift
giving and birthday celebrations for
adults and kids alike i thought
i would have my two favorite people in
the world on the podcast
ryan is here but bex is here as well
we got a lot to talk about today before
we do
i am going to ask you for a birthday
gift
whatever you want you want another tie
clip
that'd be nice thank you maybe some
cufflinks for the shirt
do you want some plaid boxers
yeah i mean i want the most thoughtless
gift you can think of
like on your way to the store i remember
once i forgot to give my mom a christmas
gift
oh and i was like driving over to her
house and i'm like oh no the only place
that's open right now is the stop and go
in lebanon ohio and uh so i was driving
over to and i'm like there was i don't
know why would i get her i don't even
know what i'm
probably something absurd like that a
pack of philly's blunts cigars
anyway uh i do want a birthday gift from
you i only ask for this once a year most
podcasts ask for
this every single episode twice an
episode
if you get a chance go on to apple
podcast and rate and review this episode
for my birthday
if you appreciate the podcast if you
want find value in it
go ahead and leave a rating over there
it's just applepodcast.com
the minimalist even if you listen on a
different app if you look listen on
spotify or overcast or google podcast or
whatever
go ahead and leave a review on apple
podcast
if you'd like to celebrate my birthday
with me i thought we would start with a
metaphor
i sent you both a picture and
jordan i sent this to you as well if you
could put this on the youtube video if
you're watching this
on youtube the minimalist dot com
slash youtube or youtube.com the
minimalist either one of them will take
you there
there is a picture i saw of a
lamborghini
and that's really what you want for your
birthdays
at one point maybe when i was six yeah
dude i used to have the trapper keeper
with the freaking
lamborghini on the front of it and you
wouldn't even know what to do with the
lamborghini when you got it
no right and and yet this picture i
i sent to you it was a lamborghini
you'll see it here on the screen
on youtube it's just covered in dust
yeah it's in a barn yeah look like
there's a
barn in the midwest it's covered with
dust yeah
yeah it reminded me of there's pictures
of like abandoned sports cars in dubai
so like people go to dubai they'll buy a
lamborghini they'll buy
you know maserati whatever it is and
like in the airport parking lot
there's just like all these sports cars
covered in dust
because they buy the car they drive it
you know they have their trip
drive to the airport get on their plane
and they never see it again they just
abandon it they just abandon it but
isn't that
the metaphor for a lot of gifts since
today we're talking about gifts birthday
gifts in particular
quite often we feel obligated to give
someone something
and then even though even if we thought
we really wanted something the
lamborghini
right it's there collecting dust after a
month a year
whatever and and the object of our
desire
quickly becomes forgotten about or
becomes this object of never-ending
maintenance
and so whenever we we give
something to someone we're also giving
them the burdens
of that thing yeah yeah it's uh
it's crazy man like the the thought of
having a lamborghini like even as one of
the minimalists like it sounds cool
you know like it's not my object a like
you know tesla is more like my object a
uh-huh but i also understand like yeah
getting that
um well now you don't have that that
anticipation anymore so you quickly just
kind of
lose interest when you get it yes indeed
yeah so during the minimal episode today
we're going to talk about birthday gifts
on the maximal we're going to talk about
a bunch of
alternatives to birthday gifts answer
some more questions over there
patreon.com
slash the minimalist every thursday we
do a private podcast episode with our
guests
much longer deeper dive into something
that we're talking about
completely separate episode by the way
before we get into that you can see if
you are watching this on youtube we have
this gift wrap paper behind us yes and i
have a different color
something that matches my olive skin
more yes indeed
i think they're calling that evergreen
and and so we are in the studio space
i'm gonna give you a full
update on the maximal episode of exactly
what we're doing here what we have
coming in in the coming weeks and months
we're working with a very talented set
designer her name is beulah
and it's going to be stunning in here in
the meantime
we've gif wrapped the space yes and
we're going to be unveiling that
unwrapping the gift for you slowly it's
our present
from us to you it's really a present
from our patrons so if you are a
supporter of the podcast
not only do you get all the stuff that
we create
on the back end on the private podcast
but you are creating this
for our patrons or for our listeners
as well yeah thank you patrons yes
indeed let's dive into some of these
questions we have let's do it
asha from facebook has a question for us
ryan instead of spending lots of money
and giving expensive gifts what are some
meaningful ways
to celebrate birthdays well i
you know i think that depends on the
person sure right
and so i think we want a blanket one
size
fits all here's the meaningful way to
celebrate
a birthday yeah here's the list of 10
appropriate
gifts that you can give someone right
now bex and i
we have a daughter ella just turned
eight last month
and so her birthday celebration is going
to look a little different from my
birthday celebration for my 40th
birthday right
yes and well how do you know that well
you can either say well everyone
should celebrate the same way here is
the
sort of cookie cutter model or you
simply ask the person
what is the most meaningful way for you
to celebrate
because if you are expecting some sort
of
gift who am i to say that you shouldn't
get a gift now it's not my obligation
i'm not obligated to give you a gift and
with ella
we had a party at the park and she had
a bunch of friends come over and of
course the invitation encouraged people
to not bring
gifts that works 100 of the time right
yeah if you just say no gifts
then people listen and they respect your
your boundaries and your requests
immediately right it worked zero percent
by the way isn't that funny
every child brought some type of gift
what do you think that is although i do
think that
the encouragement to like you know not
bring them or like hey it's okay
to not bring them i do think that helped
people like
bring it down a few levels and right and
make it a little bit more
like casual so it could have been worse
is what you're saying
it could have been more intense yeah she
could have gotten a dusty lamborghini
yeah so we had all these kids come out
and the funny thing is there was sort of
this gift opening
celebration moment where ella's tearing
into the gifts all the kids are really
excited about
it in the moment it was cute it was it
was very cute but very quickly the gifts
were
thrown to the side in the grass yeah
except there was one gift they all
played with it was a kite
so there was someone brought a kite and
so they all got to play with the kite
but they were all focused on everything
else other than
the gifts it really was the cliche of
of the experience of it all but it was
actually
all the kids playing around that they
were sword fighting at one point
i brought real swords i was very lord of
the flies for a while
i mean yeah and one kid got hit by one
of these little fake swords and he got
mad and he picked up a shoe and started
throwing shoes at other kids
oh wow it sounds like an amazing party i
know right
they had so much fun though they had a
ton of fun so much fun
i'll tell you one thing we did do we had
a pinata although
ella knew a few days in advance she
found it in the closet the pinata and i
was telling her that she's like what's
in it i told her it was filled with raw
broccoli yeah she was not happy about
that
but uh the kids really enjoyed the
pinata they enjoyed the time together
they enjoyed because uh we had these um
uh club sodas you know the fizzy drinks
they're just fizzy water basically
and they really enjoy those because they
just took them out started shaking them
and exploding them on each other
and they thought that that was probably
the best gift out of everything is
they just in fact if we face of lacroix
yeah we should have done
uh maybe 15 20 cases of lacroix and they
were just spraying them all over each
other oh that's great
i think maybe next time for the ninth
birthday we just say
uh gifts are encouraged one case of
clear lacroix a plain lacroix
and they will and make sure your kids
bring their swimsuits basically
i think it's i think it's crazy that
like people
you ask you ask them like to respect
some boundaries you set up you set up
the boundaries
and then people are like oh
that's a great idea but i'm gonna do
what i want to do
yes when it's when it's funny because it
seems like a selfless act
oh well i'm well you know i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna deprive the child
of a toy like i'm gonna go ahead and
give that but you're not doing what the
child wants you're not doing what the
parents want you're just doing what you
want to do
you're doing it for you yes and there's
a couple reasons for that one
is you think it's what you're supposed
to do it's what your society your
culture your religion
your peer group has told you this is
what i'm supposed to do
and the other part of it is oh you know
what
i i what does this gift say about me
and so it's still about you and and what
does not getting a gift
say about me what as though there is an
implicit message
yes we said no gifts but we were just
being coy we actually want big gifts
yeah no that's not what we actually want
and the other thing too is this oh it's
my love language
which let's say in some hypothetical
parallel universe gift giving is a love
language
you're and you're enforcing your love
language onto someone else you're not
even considering what their
love language is yeah if ryan shows up
to the podcast or speaking greek
right i'm not going to understand him
exactly
and here's what i'll say gift giving is
not a love language there's no such
thing as a love language it is a like
language
and i think we get really confused with
love and like you know bex and i do a
podcast a couple times a month it's
called how to love
and it's really not about how to it's
about understanding what love
is and what we're trying to do is
explore this sort of deeper
understanding of love and
and really i i was talking to her on the
podcast of the day i used to love what
you
would say to people when you first
started dating you would say i'm in like
with you
because that's so much more honest yeah
right
this because really what we're saying
gift giving i understand the four love
language five
love languages whatever six seven eight
love languages now if you look at
different blog posts online
and and what people are really saying is
this is how i show affection
we mistake affection for love yeah we
mistake liking for love as well
and we mistake gift giving for
contribution because that's really when
someone says that their love language is
gift giving
they want to contribute to another
person's life and let's say that person
their
gif uh their leveling which is also gift
getting
uh that again they want someone to
contribute
to their lives so uh giving a gift
actually
in a lot of ways like you said with the
stop and go example gift giving is one
of the
most it can be one of the most
thoughtless ways to contribute to
someone else
yeah yeah when you are just going to the
mall shopping for inspiration thank god
man
and maybe not miss that and because you
feel like you have to do it
dude i used to walk around the mall and
like you know i had a budget like 15 20
for friends and family and i got a list
of people i want to buy for
and yeah i'm walking around the mall
like okay
looking for inspiration something
inspire me right something tell
you know something jump out at me and
say hey you should get this for your
grandmother
you should get this whatever i mean
that's worked
five percent of the time like i can only
think of one gift right where that's
happened and my grandma still has it's
like the statue and actually is a really
beautiful thing
but man like that's such an exception
that's not
the rule and even then you'd be
completely fine without it yeah
and it doesn't make up for any sort of
deficiencies in the relationship either
and i think when we think of gift giving
as a love language
i'll often say that gift giving is no
more of a love language than pig latin
is a romance language
and and so if there's a deficiency in
the relationship we try to
the same way we try to fill the void and
our sort of the the god-shaped hole as
we discussed recently on on a former
episode
we is that what you call it
[Laughter]
we try to we try to you fill the void
in in us with stuff we try to fill the
void in our quote-unquote relationship
with someone else oh i
i've been neglectful i have been
uncaring i've been unkind i've been
resentful
yeah do you think you're gonna make it
up with a gift right
all of a sudden you get someone a gift
and now all those things go away right
no
what it does is it covers them up for a
moment it covers up with excitement yes
but excitement doesn't fix anything it's
like it's like putting a tarp over
quicksand yeah you're still going to
sink into it
now for my birthday a little bit
different from ella's i'm not gonna have
a sword fight that i know of i mean
unless shawn and jordan come over and
uh bring real swords but uh if
i used to be back in my corporate days i
was
i lived the life of an extrovert and so
on my birthday i
simply asked for one thing leave me the
hell alone
i would go to the movies by myself
i would turn my phone off and i would
just spend time by myself because
it was this this thirst that i had for
solitude that was never
quenched in my daily life well now every
day is a bit of a celebration i get the
joy of
we're filming some stuff for a new film
project we're working on
this week and i'm going to talk about
the details on it on the private podcast
this week but
i don't want to do it let the cat out of
the bag too soon publicly right
but we were filming that and like it was
truly joyous
and and i remember in the moment like oh
yeah like we don't have to wait
for these moments we get to enjoy this
right now i don't have to wait and look
at the rear view and say oh that was
great
it was great right then in the moment
and
and i've noticed that i get enough
solitude now i spend most of my time
alone thankfully the people closest to
me understand
my need for that that i don't need to
well on my birthday leave me alone
because the only time i get alone
no my birthday for me is just like any
other day
and turning 40 or 35 or 21 or whatever
it doesn't matter it's another day
yeah yeah i uh yeah
i don't know man it's funny because i
haven't really thought because i turned
40 this year and i haven't really
given it too much thought but i've
mentioned it a couple times and people
are like where are you going for your
40th birthday i'm like oh do i need to
go somewhere for my 40th birthday yeah
is that what i'm supposed to do
right am i i actually coincidentally i
do have a trip kind of plan
uh trying to plan a trip to ireland
towards the end of the year so
if someone asks me that i'll just be
like last time someone asked me i'm like
well i got a trip to ireland plan like
later this year but
just it just kind of happens to coincide
with my 40th birthday
but you know the fact is is that um i am
uh
i am not going to admit 40. we are
we are boycotting 40. i am at least okay
i'm either 39 or 41.
so you're turning 41 this year
interesting i'm turning i'm turning 39
for the second time okay
now you're just skipping 40 all together
to round out this question about
celebrations
ultimately it's about the person who is
being celebrated
and what would add value to their life
because if
we said well you know i really like to
be left alone on my birthday so
you know what we should do with ella we
should just leave her alone on her
birthday
she would be really sad and upset by
that yeah so so i like this so really
like the answer here is ask the person
you know what they need or what they
want and if and i've done this before
like i don't really need anything i'm
like great
that i don't have to get you anything
would there be a meaningful way that we
could celebrate this if so let me know
right absolutely we have a question oh
by the way before we get into the next
question
asha let me send you a copy of our new
book it comes out in
two weeks it's called love people use
things it comes out july 13th
you can pre-order it wherever you
pre-order books and
there is well there are some rules for
living with less in there
one of those rules is the minimalist
gift getting rule not the gift rule
but the gift getting rule so you'll find
that in love people use things we'll put
a link to that in
the show notes as well amy in australia
has a question for us
we've spoken to our families about
wanting their time and attention
not any gifts when jack spoke to his mum
about this
she got really offended and refused to
listen to the fact that we genuinely
don't want any presents
we haven't told her that most of the
gifts that she has given us
over the last few years have actually
been donated as they haven't been things
that add value to our lives
this has included eight gluten-free
cookbooks that she's given us
over the last few years do we tell her
that we end up donating the gifts that
she gives us
or do we accept that providing us with
gifts seems to make her happy
and so do we accept that so it's funny
because
you actually don't have the power to
make her happy
yeah or you don't have the power to make
her understand either
oh yes and that's where i think a lot of
people get caught up they're like oh
well they don't understand so then i'm
going to go ahead and bend to them but
it's like it's not
it's not your responsibility to make
someone happy and it's not your
responsibility to make someone
understand
yeah bex you you deal with this quite a
bit especially with ella you know
certain family members will get gifts
and
it's it feels like they're it's
intentional but it's still a lot of a
sense of obligation so you still have
they're doing something because they
want to show that they
care they want to make you happy they
want to make ella happy
and yet you've mult on multiple
occasions
said hey this isn't how we get value
yeah i think that you know it's
important
to to keep mentioning that you know your
preferences
that maybe give experiences or
you know gift cards or things like that
for
consumables even with kids like one of
ella's favorite gifts from her birthday
a couple weeks ago
was like gift cards to the local ice
cream place
you know so it's like um they don't they
don't
they can still you know give you things
or at least this is the the stance that
that we have kind of taken with it is we
still
graciously accept gifts but we
we strongly prefer these sort of
non-tangible
type things um but also like for me
one thing that that's helped is like
is letting it go to be honest like
we can say our preferences and
we can we can try to communicate
effectively with the people
who are around us whether they're family
members or friends or whatever
but at the end of the day it's like
if they're still giving you gifts like
it's kind of on them
yeah and i let it go like i just stop i
don't worry about it
you know and so like yeah ella got a
dozen you know small
gifts at her birthday party because
there were a dozen kids there
and it's like you know some of them
almost immediately went in the trash
just because they broke
or like they were kind of disposable
gifts
like they were only really designed for
like um
one comes to mind i have no idea what
it's called but it's like this little
thing that like you wash
under water and it like emerges like you
wash off this paint and then it emerges
as something else
okay like but the thing that emerges is
like she's never gonna play with that
yes right and so like the whole thing i
know
that's something it's a great metaphor
the whole thing was like just
you know the excitement of washing off
watching off the pain and see what comes
out of it
and then it's done cool but in a way
they bought her that experience
the thing that's left over now i also
get the point of like but
what about all this waste and the
problem is i can't control the waste of
other people
if sean in his time off like decides he
wants to burn
trash out in riverside county right
there's nothing i can do about that
right right right and and it's not up to
me to control him i think that's
an incredibly stupid thing to do and
thankfully i know sean well enough to
know he would never do that
yeah right but it that's a a perot
exaggeration an example of yes other
people
are doing things that damage the
environment and you can ask them hey i
don't want
gifts but if they or you can say hey i
don't want you to do the thing that
damages the environment
that's not what i want i'm not telling
you to do something different
but that's not what i want i can
acknowledge that and if you continue to
do it it's no longer on me
yes and as you said a year from now
virtually none of those gifts will be
in ella's life even a day after many of
the gifts weren't in ella's life
and that's okay because if you span out
long enough by the time she's 18
certainly none of those gifts will be in
her life
right i have very few i have i think one
or two things from when i was 16 years
old
my razor that i shave with is still the
same razor i use when i was 16. it's so
crazy
and my my wallet not my wallet but my
checkbook
it's like this leather checkbook i got
as a gift a birthday gift
i still had the shaquille o'neal rookie
card you gave me for my
birthday my birthday in the fifth grade
really yes oh my gosh
yeah it's like in my i have a like one
little bag of uh like photos and like
just
little childhood stuff uh-huh and it's
totally in there man i looked that up
the other day it's worth like
60 bucks man oh my god
fine i'll split it with you yeah what if
it ends up being like millions of
dollars
i mean it would never do that but anyway
amy here oh go ahead because
i was just gonna say i want to add
something too though like especially
with family
you know where it's like a reoccurring
gift-giving situation especially with
ella
is ella you know she's yes she's
our child but like she's her own
separate person
yes and so especially now that she's
getting older
i don't i try really hard we try really
hard not to impose
our values onto her and so she does
enjoy getting gifts she thinks it's
great she doesn't see
her family very often her extended
family and so it's a way for them to
connect
and so what i the the view that i've
taken on that
is like you know if they ask if they can
give her a gift
i give them a few options that you know
that either ella has asked for
or that you know i know she will really
enjoy and get value from
sometimes they're a little bit more
expensive and so my family members will
pull together and you know contribute
smaller amounts and and get the bigger
item for her
like roller skates for example or
something
but yeah that that seems to work really
well for our family
yeah and many of the gifts are useful
gifts too i've noticed with ella
she is actually grateful to get clothes
a lot of kids when you and i were kids
and someone got us dude socks and
underwear was like the worst gift now i
love socks and underwear
[Laughter]
i mean i don't even wear underwear so
you got me again minimalist
no so uh the thing about that is it's
understanding the preferences
of the kid right because you can get
something that's incredibly useful for a
kid
and if you're doing that then you're
sort of checking a couple different
boxes there because kids are always
getting
their clothes dirty ruining clothes
growing out of clothes and shoes and
other things
so the sort of useful side of gifts as
well and then there are the things that
are
even physical gifts that can be
experiential gifts you know something
like the kite
is a physical gift but it's not about
the kite itself just sitting in your
room
sure it's about flying the kite with her
friends what enhances or amplifies your
experience
with the people you're spending your
time with amen
amy here's the thing the gifts that your
mom gives you they are yours
they're not hers they're not your
sisters they're not your partners
they're yours you can do
whatever you want with them so uh
yes if you want to donate those books
then donate them
now are you going to go and tell your
mom that you donated them no you're not
going to just go hey mom thanks for
those books i donated to this by the way
you put it up on instagram stories
donating all these gifts my mom gave me
right like
you don't want you don't want to go out
of your way to hurt her feelings but you
know you do want to be honest with her
if she
asks you where those books are then of
course you're going to be honest with
her and you're going to express to her
that yeah i had to donate those
because i didn't have room for them and
here's the thing is like
people buy gifts to make other people
happy and if the gift that someone
has given you is a burden and it's and
it is decreasing your happiness
then their their intention is actually
the opposite is happening over their
intention so
uh you can express to your mother if it
ever comes up that you donated them
be like hey mom i know you want me to be
happy i know you want me to
to live a meaningful life so yes i got
rid of those books
because that truly does make me happier
to have less clutter i appreciate the
sentiment
but there there wasn't room for them and
i found them a better home i've done
this with with grandparents i've done
this with parents
where i'm like hey i know i've talked
several times about the paper
paperweight my grandma gave me
because you know she we write books so
she just assumes i have
like papers everywhere right yeah and
i'm likely some of those papers make it
into a book right
exactly exactly and i was just like hey
thanks for the paperweight i'm not gonna
actually use this but it's a beautiful
paperweight and i want to find it a
really good home and she was like yeah
if you could just find it a good home
that would be great
most of the gifts we get tend to be
paperweights of some sort yeah
and so your your grandma just bypassed
the
the metaphor and made it as literal as
possible right it was a beautiful
paperwork but she was also
very understanding the last thing i'll
add for amy before we wrap up this
question
is yes this might make your mom upset
that you donate these gifts and i'm
sorry but you don't actually have the
power
to make her upset let me illustrate that
in a different way an absurd way
to really show you that you don't have
that power it's only within her to
determine whether or not she is
upset let's say you wear a pair of green
tennis shoes
and anytime you wear a pair of green
tennis shoes that makes your mom
furiously upset is that your problem
or is it her problem now do you have to
change your behavior do you have to
change your preferences do you have to
change
your desires do you have to change your
wants
just because it makes your mom upset
well you're not doing anything to harm
her directly so you're not doing
anything
immoral to by getting rid of these gifts
you're simply getting rid of something
that is in the way for you now your mom
doesn't want to give you something that
is
in the way obviously she doesn't see it
as being in the way she has a difference
of perspective
but she doesn't get to determine what is
in the way for you
what isn't in the way what your
preferences are what you will find value
in
yeah she can guess she can try to help
but ultimately it's not up to her to
make you happy she wants you to be happy
but she can't make you
happy and it's not up to you to keep her
from being
upset that doesn't mean be egregious be
rude be mean
obviously you can tell from amy's
question when she called in that's not
what she wants she wants to
approach us in a loving way yeah you
don't have to announce the getting rid
of things
but i would also encourage you to not be
not to lie to her about it either right
to continue to be truthful
about your interaction it's possible to
be truthful it's possible to be
compassionate
while your mom's feelings are hurt but
the least compassionate thing you can do
is make yourself miserable because your
mom is making you feel guilty yes
amy let me send you a copy of our book
essential it's an essay collection with
12 different chapters 12
areas of living with less and one of
those areas is
minimalist gift giving there's an entire
chapter in our book essential there's
150 essays in there
in the book and then one of those
chapters is about gift giving so we have
several essays
in that book about gift giving we'll put
a link to that in the show notes as well
if you like our podcast you'll like the
audiobook version of essential or if you
want the book book or the ebook we'll
send those
to you as well ryan what time is it you
know what time it is it's time for our
lightning round where we answer your
text messages you can text your
questions and comments to 937-202-4654
yes indeed those texts
literally go to both of our phones so
you can text us an emoji of the last
thing you decluttered or maybe the gift
that you got rid of
most recently or just tell us about an
experience that you have we do respond
to people directly quite frequently
and also we send you every monday we
don't send you spam we don't send you
junk we don't send you advertisements
but we do send you
a monday morning minimal maxim every
week to start your week off
with a little bit of simplicity so you
can just send us a text message that'll
get you
on our text message list you can join
thousands of people who get
our text messages now we have a question
here from
nadine nadine i like that name how do my
spouse and i address the societal
expectations of others regarding our
choice of participation
in traditional gift-giving events such
as birthdays and christmas
we try being creative and finding
meaningful options but in order to not
become completely socially isolated
it just seems easier to comply and go
with the flow
even when it goes against our views
socially isolated
wow yeah and so we've experienced this
the last couple of years right the
social distancing
in a way that has been isolating and and
some people have had
radically different responses to that
some people
realize like oh wow i was i was doing a
lot of sort of small
talk and spending time with these
networking groups and things that
man i wasn't getting real value from i
had a dream the other night i was at a
networking event oh
like what am i doing why am i here
like i just told someone i go because
they asked me oh it was miserable
oh that so let's let's expand on that
right so
anytime we start doing things because
other people want us to do them
it makes us feel a different kind of
isolated you may not feel socially
isolated
but you you might feel a type of
loneliness
when you aren't alone because you're
with a crowd of people who have
different expectations or living up to
some sort of
societal norm and i know this question
is really about
about gift giving right and so birthday
gifts
christmas gifts but here's what stood
out to me in the question ryan
we try being creative and finding
meaningful options
but in order to not become completely
socially isolated
it seems easier to comply that's because
it is
easier of course to comply yeah it's
always easier to
comply yeah but compliance is not
meaningful
right no it's not what that does is it
you were saying you feel isolated
and i think what what it what that truth
is actually is that you get isolated
from yourself
your actions are isolating you from
yourself
you become distanced from who you truly
are and who you truly want to be
whenever we just comply
right right yeah and so compliance
when you think about compliance like you
will comply because you are forced to if
the if a police officer pulls you over
yeah it turns the sirens on the lights
and and pulls you over
it's in your best interest to comply i
feel like comply is a
it's usually a pejorative right yeah
when you ever use that in the positive
sense it's almost either
neutral or pejorative right so i can
think of a time where compliance is
yeah okay yes if i want to go order a
coffee at the blue bottle across the
street i will put on my i'll comply
with their with their rules sure put on
my shoes my shirt and my mask
right in order to to uh to get the
coffee i want to get so i will comply
with that
but yeah i i maybe i'm fine with it i'm
fine with wearing a shirt in there or a
mask in there or whatever
prefer not to wear shoes but that's a
different story
and and yet i will make sure i'm wearing
shoes i will comply with
with their rules in order to get what i
want or the alternative
is to not get coffee but i don't feel
great about having to do something that
doesn't align with the person i want to
be
now if it was if it was something more
egregious if they were like
well in fact in order to come in here
you have to wear a motorcycle helmet and
hop on one foot
i wouldn't comply right and so
and some people would you see a bunch of
people hopping in there with their
motorcycle helmets on so you have a
choice
whether or not you want to meet the
standards or the
whatever it is the expectations of this
restaurant and the same thing goes with
your friends and family
and personally i would not spend much
time developing
relationships with people who are going
to socially isolate me because i don't
want gifts
yeah i think that's important you know
there was a past episode we were talking
about like one of us is vaccinated one
of us isn't we don't have to go into the
details on that
we have just different beliefs in
general right and and
and it's not that i care whether or not
i have i have the vaccine you don't or
vice versa one of us also has the
antibodies and the other one didn't
yes that's also true right and so um
the the thing to keep in mind here is
even even if that wasn't the case like
i don't want to force my point of view
onto you
i don't want to coerce you i don't want
to persuade you
these are all not these aren't forms of
loving someone
right the coercion is never love
persuasion is not love convincing
someone
and get believe me i get it yeah i had
this essay which we're going to cover on
a future episode but you can find on our
website right now it's called
off the rack self-righteousness and it's
really about
how i spent the better part or close to
four decades
trying to convince people of my
singularly right worldview
and if i was right therefore everyone
else must who didn't agree with my exact
point must be wrong
and that inadvertently placed me on a
pedestal
so well i think sometimes what we're
doing here if someone's trying to
convince you that you should want this
gift
or you should get them a gift or
whatever it is they're
accidentally placing themselves on a
pedestal i know what is best
societally i know what's best for you
that's not true maybe you know what's
best
for you specifically but you don't know
what's best
for me and pretending that you do is a
type of of righteousness that i've
let go of in the past year or so because
uh well it's not an outfit that i wear
very well
self-righteousness that is the answer
over there i do so i think if we were to
sum up the
whole episode that we have here uh
here's my pithy answer that you can
tweet by the way during the lightning
round this is where
we do our best to answer questions with
a short shareable less than 140
character response we answer we
we put the text to these minimal maxims
in the show notes so you can copy
and share our pithy answers on social
media if you'd like
my pithy answer today is instead of
saying no to gifts say yes
to experiences if i were to rephrase
that just slightly
quite often people will will talk about
well how do i say no to this gift no
and it's like well it's not really about
saying no because our interactions with
other people
i i don't want to be the guy who's
constantly saying no no no no no
being the vice president of no yeah i i
want to be able to say yes so instead of
saying
no no don't give me any gifts what would
add value to my life sure if you're
interested in getting me a gift
then let me say yes to something else
maybe it's an experience maybe it's
coffee maybe it's a gift card for ice
cream cones
yeah or a donation in your name yeah
that's what we do with our family
for you specifically right you
participate in our gift-giving
exchange right um but
you always ask for a donation you know
to
my favorite favorite charity yeah and so
uh and if you don't have a favorite
charity you can go to givewell.org
they're
some of the most effective charities in
the world are over there or
we're working on some other project you
know ryan and i are constantly doing
these sort of
charitable things that we donate our own
money but it's a great way as well for
them to contribute they can give
get they can give a gift in your name on
on your in your behalf so if i want to
give ryan a birthday gift for his 41st
birthday
this year my second 39th birthday oh yes
his 39th second birthday no my second
39th birthday
okay so if i want to give you a hundred
bucks i could and you're like
well you know just donate it to my
favorite charity which is like
the underpants without borders charity
or whatever it is
underpants without borders whatever
whatever the charity i can do so but i
could do so on behalf of ryan nicodemus
yeah and then
if you want it needs to be a physical
gift because people feel good about that
you can you can print it out on really
nice paper on a color sheet of paper and
with the with the you could put a bow on
it you can wrap it up in
in gift wrap however you want to do it
so they open it up and then oh yeah look
you donated
to my favorite charity i feel good about
this i also got the physical
representation of that along the way but
last thing i want to say about this
is instead of saying no it's really
about saying
yes to what adds value to you this will
strengthen the bond between you and the
connection between you and other people
because i i also want to be cognizant of
i understand that as
one of the minimalists or as soon as you
call yourself a minimalist people
people can have a a particular world
view about that you know
they can judge it and say oh this person
is
judging my lifestyle by the way they
live their life
and by being open to gifts saying yes to
the the quote-unquote right kind of
gifts the the gifts that
will add value to me instead of just
saying no i don't want that
it's a way to open up that person to a
deeper understanding of
minimalism as well yeah uh my pithy
answer is an oldie but a goodie going
with the flow will lead you to the falls
so if you're in a river you stay in that
river long enough you're gonna end up
going over the falls
and that's that's literally
metaphorically if you go with the flow
you are in for a fall eventually yes
so uh get out of the river while you can
and the thing about
your the the pithy answer you have there
is it feels right to go with the flow
for a while it's
easy it's fun getting an inner tube it's
yeah it's easy
and so back to that question the
the compliance is easy
but it's not simple simple as having the
ore
and and having to go against the flow in
order to get
where you actually want to go yep if you
just go with that flow long enough it's
going to be easy but you're going to be
in for a world of hurt
eventually when you reach those those
rapids yeah
rebecca my pithy one so the best gift is
love
and ice cream or coffee
but you repeat yourself or coffee ice
cream my favorite gifts that people
send us uh it's like uh people send us
chocolate they'll send us coffee
dude i got from ireland um
i don't think you could eat it so i
ended up taking it but it was like some
like
spicy type mustard but it's nice it's
some kind of consumable
yeah um the the worst
gifts that we get is when someone
sends me a book because i already have
so many books to read
that i haven't read yet right and then
like now they're like oh i gave you this
book and like my first
initial response is to be like oh [ __ ]
now i gotta read this book yeah
there are about four people who could
send me a book yeah i and
it would be like chris ryan yes like sam
harris rob bell
you could give me a book uh-huh and
that's that's about it actually yeah
how rarely do i ever give you a book
almost never right exactly
because i know you're inundated with
books we get books all the time
in fact on the maximal episode this week
this thursday i want to talk to you
about some of the best gifts you've been
given
some examples there and also examples
specifically of some of the worst gifts
you've been giving some of the most
thoughtless gifts you've been given
we got a bunch more to talk about today
but first ryan you got something for us
here are some voicemail comments and
insights from our listeners check them
out
hey guys i'm rachel longtime listener
first time caller
i am calling to respond to something
corey said on episode 176
the un-american dream he was calling to
ask you
uh if you thought that buying a house
would be his next step
or should be his next step sounds like
he follows the dave ramsey plan
um he said he paid off all his debt and
after he
has an emergency fund safe he feels like
the expected next step would be to buy a
home
he also said that he wasn't sure if that
was something he should be doing because
he wasn't happy in his job he didn't
feel the need to put down roots where he
was
and i want to speak to that because i
did
recently sell my home due to something
like this my husband got his dream job
and required us to move
across the country but we owned a home
luckily we were able to sell the house
in
an acceptable amount of time for us to
be able to afford to move
but that does not always happen and the
markets can change suddenly so that's
something corey really needs to take
into account
when he's thinking about buying a home
and whether or not he's going to want to
move i also want to say that if you are
renting and you are doing the dave
ramsey steps
there is no reason why you can't start
saving for a home in case
you do move to somewhere amazing and you
want to put down routes there
hey this is helen from carlsbad
california i just wanted to make a
comment
about the podcast about health you guys
were talking about
snipping patterns and figuring out your
own sleep schedule
and there was something that i
accidentally figured out
a couple years ago when i had evenings
to myself
all alone in my house i had a lot of
windows in the house and i would just be
doing my own thing i could get
distracted the sun would go down
the lights would dim and suddenly it was
nine o'clock
and the house was practically pitch
black except for maybe one light
that was pretty dim in the corner and i
realized by that time that i was very
tired and i was ready for bed
and i was curious because before i was
getting up till maybe 11 00
o'clock midnight and i looked up to see
what exactly this meant and i
learned that when we are not surrounded
by artificial lighting
and we go outside maybe and we're
outside all day
our energy goes with the sun so as the
sun sets
our energy slowly declines and our body
gets ready to
rest for the night and so for those who
are having trouble with sleeping or
trying to figure out their pattern or
whatever it may be i highly suggest
doing that to keep
all the lights off except for maybe one
or two that are really necessary
and see if that helps see it as the sun
goes down
their body gets ready to sleep and they
can have a good night's rest
all right y'all thanks to bex for
joining us today
you can check out her lovely podcast
it's called how to love
you can find it on apple podcast spotify
or wherever you
pod we'll put a link to that in the show
notes as well or just head on over to
howtolove.show
for our segment right here right now
here's one thing that's going on in the
life of the minimalist and i already
mentioned ryan and i
we've been working several years on this
book i'll hold it up if you're watching
on youtube
this is called love people use things
this is an advanced copy of it it's
actually coming out in hardback
in two weeks if you pre-order the book
we're doing a special tour stop
it's a live event online in your living
room
in your living the minimalists are
coming to a living room near you
we're gonna have some special guests i
don't want to reveal them just
yet but by the time you go to the
website just go to the minimalists.com
tour you'll find the link and you get to
attend that for free
if you so there's no money there's no
tickets no ticket sales
all you have to do support us pre-order
our book
yeah check out the book uh and you can
just go to lovepeopleusethings.net to
pre-order the book or
wherever you pre-order books in fact
there are some great indie book shops
near you
you can pre-order it at your indie
bookshop all you have to do is submit a
receipt you can attend
this live event if you can't watch the
event live don't worry it'll be up for
several days
after the event airs we're gonna do a
live stream we're gonna do a q a we're
gonna have special guests
in studio and by then we'll also have
well we'll have a different set design
here as well so you'll get to see that
we're gonna broadcast live from
hollywood
and it will be your opportunity to
interact with us to answer questions to
talk about the book
finally it's going to be out there in
the world if you want a sample of
the book we have this essay here it's
called
love is more if you go to the
minimalists.com
love is more there is a essay that you
can read
it's just an excerpt from the book talks
about how we have a
love language problem you love your
husband
but you also love burritos you love your
best friend but you also love the new
matt carney album which by the way is a
really great album
it's called january flower if you want
to check out matt carney's new album you
love your daughter but you also love the
various colors of flowers in your
neighborhood one la
love involves bottomless devotion birth
from deep affection
the other a preference or fondness for
something enjoyable
and then it goes on to talk about better
a better understanding of love and
that's from the people chapter
of love people use things you can find
that excerpt
for free over at the minimalists.com
love is more for our added value segment
this week
a little birthday music here speaking of
love
to love forever is a song by william
fitzsimmons one of ryan's and my
favorite
singer-songwriters we saw him in dayton
years ago that like little bar yeah the
canal street tavern
sean is that still open i think they may
have closed that spot i think it might
be
we and it was really late i mean it must
have been 2 a.m by the time he got on
stage crazy
it was a really lovely concert it was
funny though he started off with like
all right are you all ready to be sad
but you know what uh what i remember
from that concert too i forget
what project it was but essentially he
was encouraging people
like after the show to go and get their
photo taken of like the biggest
flaw that they have on their body do you
remember this
wow yeah and like it was uh i wish i
could remember the name of the project i
probably shouldn't have brought it up
because i don't even know where to link
to it but
it was just an amazing concept of like
and then and that just speaks to william
fitzsimmons how
you know he wants you to embrace the
sadness he wants you to embrace who you
are and in a way that actually can uh
help you have a deeper appreciation for
humanity
our scars make up the best parts of us
yeah in a way yeah so enjoy this song
from william fitzsimmons it's called
to love forever it's from his new album
which is out now
the album is called ready the astronaut
by the way we have a bunch more surprise
questions this week like
is it fair to deny people the joy they
get from giving gifts how does one draw
the line between
living in the moment during celebrations
with loved ones versus
wanting to take photos to capture
memories of those moments
plus a million more questions for becks
and the minimalists
and if you want to hear all that join us
on the minimalist private podcast this
week visit
theminimalists.com support to subscribe
and get your personal link
so that our private podcast plays in
your favorite podcast app you can also
find a tour of our new studio over there
that keeps our podcast 100 advertisement
free plus you get access to
all of the archives hundreds if not
thousands of
hours of minimalism patreon.com
the minimalist or the minimalist.com
support either one will take you over
there
you can follow the minimalists on
facebook twitter and instagram at the
minimalist come to one of our live
podcast
shows visit the minimalists.com tour to
find a city near you
if you have a question comment or
minimalism tip for our podcast
email a voice memo to podcast at
theminimalists.com
you can comment on this episode at
youtube.com slash the minimalist and if
you want our show notes in your inbox
sign up for our email list over at the
minimalists.com you'll also receive
any new minimalist essays that we
publish for free
and if you leave here today with just
one message let it be this
love people and use things
because the opposite never works thanks
for listening y'all we'll see you next
time
[Music]
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing that's just feeding
your greed oh i bet that you'll be fine
without it